night sex is done I had an epiphany
we're not doing nighttime sex no more
nighttime sex I don't even think is
natural I've been thinking about this a
lot matter of fact now that music is
getting real sexy turn that down before
we have some daytime sex right yeah uh
but yeah nighttime sex I'm like I've
been realized with me my girl might yell
oh I don't want to [ __ ] night yet oh
I'm about this like morning sex are
during the day sex like nighttime sex we
just eat a big meal we're lounge on the
couch we feel fat we're laying on top of
each other we pass out at like 9:30 I'm
going to bed dumb early I'm never going
to bed this early in my entire life and
I'm realizing oh [ __ ] nighttime sex for
humans was completely about the
environment influence in us it was never
supposed to be 9 times sex I don't even
know what animals [ __ ] at night ok but
definitely not monkeys and on him you go
to the zoo you go to Safari you see the
monkeys [ __ ] during the day eyes
peeled looking for predators over their
shoulder hitting it doggystyle right you
don't see them [ __ ] tonight because
that night that's when the leopards are
out right lepers are climbing up the
trees the Panthers are out there trying
to [ __ ] you can't be squealing and [ __ ]
at night because I'm never gonna know
exactly what the [ __ ] you are and you
can't see them they can only see you the
cat's got that night vision bro I'm just
- hey listen we only [ __ ] at night we
only [ __ ] night I noticed we only
[ __ ] night because one we can't go to
bars and [ __ ] during the day we can't
meet people during the day because we're
at work if we weren't at work we'd be
[ __ ] during the day we'd be me and
people during the day it's easy to
[ __ ] night when you go to a bar and
[ __ ] some [ __ ] with one foot from
Hoboken
ok that's the easy thing to do because
you're drunk you're not getting drunk
during the day so them stands a little
higher you're [ __ ] way less when the
stands are a little higher the
inhibitions are not gone you still feel
inhibited telling you this nighttime sex
was complete [ __ ] ok it was a
function of our lifestyle as a function
of our day-to-day now that we are
quarantined now that we're locked in
we're [ __ ] at the times we're
supposed to [ __ ] morning sex I used to
hate morning's s I used to think we're
at our worst breath
breath spank okay throw your girl in a
dog look at her back in her butthole you
stare at your girl's butt hole in the
morning that food had eight hours to
pass through them intestines you know
you might be able to see a little turtle
head poking out if you put her in a dog
at a morning that's unless you got what
sometimes too much working aboard it's a
no here's the beautiful get no more no
second the dog I dog in the morning but
here's a thing my girl shits in the
morning she thinks I don't know but I
know I know she shits in the morning she
tries to get up a little bit before me I
hit snooze ii eyes snooze she got eight
minutes to get out of [ __ ] okay
yes still trying to hide sex she tries
to hide it she knows I [ __ ] I'm fine
with it here's the thing she goes in
there [ __ ] okay get out the system brush
the teeth breath is good I get up okay I
brush the teeth and now we're going at
it having sex at the time we're supposed
to have sex the rest of the day is great
okay there's no yearning there's no
feeling of insecurity or anything we
satisfied each other sexually now we can
just lean into the emotional yeah I'm
getting sappy it's all good though
we all have cravings will have voice we
need to be filled I'm telling you
morning sex is is the most natural or
daytime sex is the most natural you find
a primate find me a primate they're only
[ __ ] at night
find me something that's close to human
the only [ __ ] at night find me any
animal to [ __ ] at night bats maybe but
they're nocturnal animals that's their
day hey you're gonna have so many people
sending you every animal [ __ ] at
nights
yeah but son the animals were the eyes
you can see at night that doesn't count
that's their day they like the night
humans we're supposed to be sleeping
tonight okay we're supposed to be second
you hear that cockadoodledoo why do you
think is cockadoodledoo why do you think
why do you think it's cockadoodledoo
because we're supposed to have that
morning sex the second that rooster
starts cockadoodle in I'm telling you
man this whole thing was environmental
we were never supposed to [ __ ] I we
had to we had
we're a rare species where we can [ __ ]
no matter what environmental factors
exist certain species our environment
dependent in their sexual appetite right
they can only [ __ ] very certain see
that's the Apple tight yeah you did see
hey bro apple bottom jeans got me
thinkin le I'm just saying there are
certain species they need to [ __ ] during
certain seasons right okay they're only
at heat during certain times of the year
maybe even certain times of the day that
exists in certain species humans no you
get in where you fit in but we're
supposed to get it in during the daytime
when the light is out when the Sun is
shinin bro I mean that 100% I mean that
hundred-percent I've had a lot of weird
[ __ ] a lot of weird also also I know
that we all know this that pulling out
is unnatural
but here's how you further know it's
it's unnatural right it's easy to pull
out you bustin your girl's stomach or
back or something like that right you
can't do that to a chimpanzee because
there's [ __ ] hair all over them a
little crazy bro I might be I'm just
sayin it's a pain in the ass to wash it
off it's gonna get all knotted up in the
hair it's not part of their culture
they're not having sex for just pleasure
they're having sex with procreation
we're having sex for pleasure
so you think primates care about dried
come on their back when they've never
had try these at each other no they're
not throwing fusillade each other
throwing pieces at us at each other - no
I think they just throw down it's like
hopscotch it would be the best at hops
just bounce they could play with
themselves
real talk I guess that's what jumping
rope is anyway single bedroom homes you
lived in a log cabin your kids go to
school okay
Abraham Lincoln log cabin had brothers
and sisters did he not say what I don't
know Lincoln I don't know boys
University
Elementary School he was walking miles
to school every single day
my book was a lawyer bro he must have
got an education you couldn't just go
out there and say you're a lawyer I
don't think so if that was the case it'd
be lit you really should be able to say
you're a lawyer like what are they
learning I don't like you having sex at
the border today and I'm feeling good
everyone listen point is this let's just
get to the main point okay let's just
get to the main point
animals are not [ __ ] at night unless
they're nocturnal animals and
technically night is their day okay see
what I'm saying yeah if you're nocturnal
that's your time to shine that's your
day literally time to shine okay we're
not nocturnal weird 'eternal whatever
that one is okay nocturnal
I think weird a turtle bro hey listen
we're just turning back so if you're a
turtle animal like us you should be
[ __ ] in the morning get your day
start with some [ __ ] your skinniest your
girl's skinniest you both look the best
the breath is you own bin is bad but you
both look the best go at it you knock
boots in the morning I promise you I
promise you during quarantine there's
gonna change your life it's gonna feel
the way it should 100% okay